[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
luke here at the outdoor boys youtube
channel let me take you back to 2015
when my family was a little bit smaller
and my youtube
channel is a little bit younger to a
video that you've probably
never seen welcome to our 13 day
alaskan adventure
[Music]
me and tommy rolled in about 10 30 last
night local time
but we've got a fun day planned we're
gonna drive up to the
sitting valley and go to the cash
whitner river
and see if we can land some silver
salmon
back in 2015 my family owned a cabin on
the banks of the cash whitner river just
a little bit south of talkeetna alaska
so we went up there to spend a couple
days with my sister's family
riding four wheelers doing picnics and
camping and of course
catching lots of salmon
yeah i'm sure you would have to fire is
not the place
well we didn't catch any fish that first
day but we still had a ball and tommy
sure didn't seem to mind he had a ball
playing in the mud getting wet
and hanging out with his family
[Music]
there we go
you just did
[Laughter]
so we caught four uh silvers they're not
big ones but they're
decent
okay
[Music]
it's just like a river
there you go my arm's getting tired
see the moose
oh yeah
hey you're wet
well it's five in the morning in alaska
when you get up before the sun rises in
the summertime you know you're getting
up early
on the fourth day me and my father got
up before the sunrise and drove up north
to talkeetna alaska to go on a salmon
fishing charter
with phantom river charters we've since
used their services several time and
always had a ball
so i'll make sure to put their
information down in the video
description below
oh there you go
[Music]
so
yeah wait
up
[Music]
the fish we were catching here were
called chum salmon or dog salmon and
they are a load of fun to catch
but in this area we were only allowed to
keep three salmon per day
and our favorite salmon to eat were the
silver salmon like this one right here
so we let all the other types of salmon
go and just kept our three silvers i got
a dolly too
what a beautiful fish
[Applause]
got no way i'm going up there
[Applause]
you
after a great day fishing with my dad i
went down to the talkeetna
roadhouse to eat a reindeer sausage
pastry
enjoy a little time with my dad and head
back to anchorage
when we got back to anchorage i took
tommy down to bnj's sporting goods to
pick them up
some baby-sized rain gear these little
grundens are made for toddlers
and are just awesome
next they took tommy down to ship creek
in downtown
anchorage this is a place that locals go
to catch a salmon during their lunch
break or after work
but it's also a place that you can go
and rent some fishing gear
but we came down just to watch the sand
later on that day i took tommy down to
one of my favorite fly fishing
spots and tommy up to this point had
been with me on a lot of fishing trips
but never really
held the rod before and so this was the
first time he ever got
to hold the rod and reel in his very own
fish
[Music]
beautiful
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
uh
[Music]
sometimes teaching catch and release can
be tricky
you want to hold him come here tom hold
him
here
hold up hold it with your hands like
this
look at the camera and see cheese
[Applause]
the next day me my father and tommy took
a little road trip to whittier alaska
about 45 minutes south of anchorage
along the way we saw salmon and went
through the second longest tunnel
in north america you see a fish
when you head to whittier you gotta go
through the second longest tunnel in
north america
but even though it's several miles long
it's only one lane and you have to share
it with both directions of traffic
and with the railroad
so in order to avoid an accident you
have to wait your
turn but the weight is well worth it
now on this trip our purpose in going to
whittier
was to see if we couldn't catch some
salmon and when we got there we were not
disappointed
oh my goodness i think we came at the
right time
[Music]
nice
[Music]
pink salmon
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh yeah wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
okay
now tommy at that age was obsessed with
fishing and his very first word
was fish so when me and my dad saw how
many fish were down there in whittier i
decided to come back the next day
and let tommy have a go at catching a
fish all by himself
at the tender age of two and a half
years old
[Applause]
you got him no no just walk walk over
here walk over here
you got it that's a big one
here hold your fish hold your fist
no no time don't
oh you got another one good for you tom
you're so strong tommy come on you're
gonna line them in
look at the teeth on him
[Applause]
bye-bye
there you go tommy good job
tommy
you got ourselves a donut
yeah you caught a fish tom
on the eighth day we decided to head
back up to the cabin with the whole
family
to do a little salmon fishing a little
four-wheeling and just
you know have a great
you time but like you said you start
with
there we go all right
look at that
[Applause]
you took your boots off and now you're
standing in the water
a beepy [ __ ] it's a
[ __ ] box on the second day
nathan my six-month-old son woke
everybody up at 5am
so i decided to take nathan on his very
first
fishing trip
[Music]
he turns and runs into the net
got it
my brother and his kids joined us up at
the cabin and he brought some 22 rifles
and pistols so we did a little bit of
target shooting and it was just
a fun time to spend with all of our
extended family
up at my parents
[Music]
um
[Music]
this trip wasn't just about fishing it
was also about introducing nathan to my
extended family
mom where's the toy box you're okay me
can i go get your giraffe
and we had just a great time with all
the nieces and nephews and
uncles and aunts getting to play with
the boys many of whom
had never had a chance to meet nathan
it was also a chance to show my kids all
the unique things about alaska like
airstrips in people's backyards mooses
in people's front yards and
at-home ammo delivery and fish bonkers
at the grocery store
on the 11th day we drove about an hour
north to the city of palmer to take the
kids
to a reindeer farm and they had a ball
[Music]
[Music]
after the reindeer farm we headed back
to anchorage and i showed my family
one of my favorite burger joints which
is the arctic road runner on the banks
of the campbell creek
just had a great time and then we went
over to our local church and our family
got together for a big party so i
strapped a gopro to tommy
and turn the blues
[Music]
you ready to go on an airplane tommy
one of becca's favorite things to do in
alaska is go on float plane
flight scene trip so on the 12th day we
made sure she got to do exactly that
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
tommy stay here
after the fly scene trip we went to
gerdwood alaska to take the winter creek
trail
and the winter creek hand tram across
the gorge
it was so cool
[Music]
do
[Music]
thank you
so now daddy's carrying tommy and he's
carrying nathan
you fell in the mud i smell something oh
yeah tommy's diaper totally exploded
diarrhea down the back of my neck on
that hike
that was uh that was a memorable dad
moment
the beluga whale should be right in here
oh
look at that there's a martin
yeah that little martin just ran under
our feet
you see some beluga whales becca uh
that way not too bad for driving down
the road huh
bye bye beluga whales
on our last day in alaska we decided to
drive down to seward which is a
beautiful port town
and go explore the seward sea life
center
and we just had a great time it was a
wonderful way
to finish off a wonderful trip
[Music]
is
yeah you see it looks like a little king
crab
[Music]
i hope you enjoyed this video because
this is just one of many of our family
travel adventure videos and i'll put a
link in the description to our travel
adventure playlist
down below make sure to check out that
playlist for all of our many
international
and domestic travel adventures including
many more trips to alaska both in the
summer and the winter time
and don't forget to click subscribe to
the outdoor boys youtube channel
for new videos every saturday thanks for
watching
[Music]